Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
La déconfiture du Maghreb.
Précisons que nous nous tiendrons
à la fraction territoriale
la plus connue de nous,
Français,
à savoir de trois pays,
Algérie, Maroc et Tunisie,
cette Afrique du Nord
jadis colonisée par la France.
Nous nous intéresserons
moins à l'histoire coloniale
de ces pays, diverse dans sa forme,
que diversement ressentie,
qu'au présent de ces trois pays
restés proches de la France
par des populations mêlées,
des échanges
économiques et culturels,
des relations politiques
non dénuées de tensions
et une commune appréhension
sécuritaire
vis-à-vis du terrorisme.
Au-delà de ce voisinage,
nous chercherons à mettre l'accent
sur la situation économique
et politique de ce Maghreb arabe.
Qu'il s'agisse des difficultés
économiques et sociales,
qui se sont aggravées
avec la crise du Covid,
de l'instabilité politique
suite à ce qu'on a appelé
les Printemps arabes,
qui se sont traduits par la
contestation des jeunes générations,
de la poussée islamiste entraînant
une régression de la condition des
femmes et d'autres discriminations,
du terrorisme,
à l'enseigne d'Al-Qaida
et d'autres officines
djihadistes.
Mais aussi des difficultés
de ces trois pays
à coopérer entre eux,
aucune intégration économique
les regroupant,
de leur rivalité régionale
à incarner le leadership
auprès de l'Afrique
comme de l'Europe,
de leurs conflits territoriaux
à propos du Sahara occidental,
bref, de leur désunion
et même, il faut bien le dire,
de la déconfiture
socio-économique, politique
et stratégique de cette région.
Nous allons chercher à comprendre
ce malaise arabe
avec mes invités
que je vous présente.
Rachid Temal,
vous êtes sénateur, PS,
c'est-à-dire Parti socialiste,
du Val-d'Oise,
mais vous présidez également
le groupe d'amitié
France-Algérie
au Sénat. Jean Dufourcq,
vous êtes contre-amiral
et vous êtes chercheur,
vous avez été
rédacteur en chef de la Revue
de défense nationale.
Hakim El Karoui,
vous êtes politologue et aujourd'hui
consultant et également essayiste.
Et Pierre Lellouche,
vous avez été ministre,
député, et vous êtes consultant
sur les relations internationales.
Alors, la question qui se pose,
c'est qu'il y a eu ce qu'on a appelé
le Hirak en Algérie
en 2019.
Le premier Printemps arabe
s'est situé
en Tunisie en 2011.
Le Maroc a pactisé
avec le parti islamique
pour former un gouvernement.
De tous ces changements,
de toutes ces révolutions,
selon le proverbe français,
on pourrait dire
tout change
pour qu'à la fin, rien ne change.
Quel est votre avis,
Rachid Temal ?
-Vous parlez de trois situations
qui ont des vraies différences.
Pour la Tunisie, ça a bien commencé,
mais ça termine
quasiment pire qu'avant.
L'évolution du régime actuel,
que ce soit sur les institutions
ou la pratique du pouvoir,
est assez compliquée.
Sur l'Algérie,
c'est vrai qu'on a le sentiment
que tout est fait
pour revenir à la case départ.
Sur le Maroc,
il y a quand même une capacité
à se régénérer, je trouve,
démocratiquement
qui est un peu plus loin.
C'est trois situations différentes,
mais qui ont un point commun,
c'est-à-dire la difficulté à la fois
des sociétés assez figées
face à un pouvoir
qui quand même bloque les choses.
Ces trois pays-là ont un peu
du mal à concevoir
ce qu'est le 21e siècle
et notamment
l'évolution de leurs populations
comme société libre.
Il y a beaucoup de points communs,
beaucoup de différences,
Voilà ce que je peux dire
sur cette comparaison.
-Pierre Lellouche,
qu'en pensez-vous ?
*-Je pense
que vous aviez raison
dans votre question.
Plus ça change,
plus c'est la même chose.
Le régime marocain s'est maintenu
en cooptant dans un premier temps
la mouvance islamiste,
et puis, il l'a
en quelque sorte enzymée,
puisqu'ils ne sont plus
au gouvernement,
le roi est toujours là, solidement.
Et le pays, ma foi, se développe
et se développe
plutôt bien en Afrique.
La situation en Algérie est
absolument inchangée,
c'est-à-dire que les mêmes
sont toujours au pouvoir,
mélange de militaire
et d'appareil sécuritaire,
qui se maintient au pouvoir
et qui vit,
comme l'a dit d'ailleurs à juste
titre le président de la République,
dans des crises permanentes
avec l'ancien colonisateur,
exploitant une rente mémorielle
qui ne s'épuise jamais.
Voilà. Donc ils sont
solidement au pouvoir.
Et les Tunisiens sont revenus
vers un régime ultra autoritaire
sans Parlement,
une dimension ouvertement raciste
à l'encontre
des populations subsahariennes
qu'il est en train
de nous exporter en France. C'est
assez cataclysmique pour la Tunisie
qui est extrêmement pauvre
et qui est en crise très profonde.
C'est un état normal,
dictatorial, autoritaire
et dans une gabegie
économique considérable en Algérie.
Le pays qui s'en sort le mieux,
c'est le Maroc,
qui a surmonté tout ça.
Et la France réussit le prodige
de se disputer avec tout le monde
et, pour la première fois,
de se disputer en même temps
avec l'Algérie et le Maroc,
ce qui est sans précédent
dans l'histoire. D'habitude...
-On va rentrer dans le détail,
Pierre Lellouche, mais d'abord,
Hakim El Karoui, alors, on a entendu
ce qui est dit sur les trois pays
et notamment la Tunisie,
c'est votre avis ?
-Oui, la Tunisie invente,
la Tunisie est
dans l'accélération du temps.
Ils sont arrivés à la démocratie
avec un peu de retard,
y compris par rapport à
leur situation sociale et éducative,
parce que la Tunisie
est très éduquée
depuis très longtemps
et puis, il y a eu
10 ans de démocratie
avec un vice original
qui était la Constitution.
Les Tunisiens ont fait
une Constitution en 2013
que le monde entier a applaudie,
qui était une Constitution
pour les Norvégiens,
fondée sur du consensus.
Il y a eu une alliance
entre la gauche et les islamistes
pour que personne
n'ait le pouvoir. Le pouvoir
a été réparti partout et il n'a
donc été exercé par personne.
Sauf les partis se sont mis d'accord
pour se répartir les postes.
Résultat,
ils n'ont pris aucune décision.
Les espoirs nés de la révolution,
du Printemps arabe, etc.,
ont très, très vite été déçus.
Et puis, il y a eu un glissement
vers un système
de plus en plus autoritaire
avec l'appui des jeunes.
C'est ça qui est extraordinaire.
Les soutiens du président actuel
sont d'abord des jeunes.
Il a fait campagne, pas pour dire
qu'il gérerait mieux la Tunisie,
mais qu'il la débarrasserait
des voleurs.
C'est de son point de vue
ce qu'il est en train de faire.
Il a installé une Constitution
ouvertement dictatoriale
avec un blanc-seing des Européens,
pas des Américains,
et il est en train de détruire
tous les corps intermédiaires,
les partis, les élus.
On pensait que c'était impossible
de faire tomber les islamistes,
c'est fait.
Il a changé la Constitution.
On pensait que c'était impossible.
Il a supprimé
toute liberté de la presse.
Il s'en prend aux hommes d'affaires
et la suivante,
c'est évidemment la France.
-Oui. Alors, Jean Dufourcq,
vous venez d'entendre ce constat,
quel est le vôtre en tant que,
j'allais dire, expert stratégique ?
-Moi, je ne partagerai pas la
totalité de ce qui vient d'être dit
dans la mesure où je pense
qu'il y a quelque chose
qui a beaucoup changé quand même,
c'est la jeunesse.
Et je pense
que l'intervention de la jeunesse
dans le cours politique,
telle qu'elle s'est présentée
en Tunisie et en Algérie,
montre qu'une force se crée,
qu'elle s'exprime,
qu'elle a un certain degré
d'intervention qui reste
pacifique et tout change
pour que rien ne change, non,
il se passe quelque chose.
Je me pose la question,
une question de chercheur :
n'y a-t-il pas aujourd'hui
la naissance d'une espèce de
conscience d'une jeunesse maghrébine
qui dépasse les frontières
et les nationalismes ?
-Justement,
je voulais
vous interroger sur ce point précis.
Ces pays maghrébins restent
des pays jeunes,
avec des jeunesses
qui sont à la fois
en révolte et, pour nombre
d'entre eux, acculés au chômage,
notamment les diplômés
qui cherchent à émigrer.
Ils sont éloignés du pouvoir
et le pouvoir semble les ignorer.
Comment vous expliquez ce décalage ?
Même s'il y a un réveil
de la jeunesse,
mais cette jeunesse
n'est pas intégrée,
alors qu'elle est une force vive.
-Elle est une force vive,
elle a aussi
avec une certaine sagesse cherché
à établir son autorité autrement
que par le rapport de force direct.
Et il y a là une façon intéressante
de regarder l'évolution
d'une société qui est
de plus en plus différenciée
entre les générations,
les générations qui montent,
qui sont aussi majoritaires
dans ces trois pays,
ont une façon d'exprimer
leurs préoccupations,
leurs rêves, leur esprit
de décision, qui est nouvelle.
Nous devrions
être peut-être plus attentifs.
Nous pensons toujours
au jeu politique.
Nous sommes des experts
de ce qui se passe à Alger
ou au Maroc, des rapports de force
entre les différents
courants politiques,
mais sait-on assez ce qu'il y a
dans la tête des jeunes ?
Je suis en contact
par mes anciens étudiants,
j'enseignais beaucoup ici,
en France,
à des Français qui avaient des
origines maghrébines et qui restent
très connectés
à leurs pays d'origine.
Ils nous disent
des choses nouvelles.
-On va rentrer là-dedans.
Je voudrais avoir votre avis,
à tous d'ailleurs,
tous les quatre, Jean Dufourcq
vient de s'exprimer, mais Pierre
Lellouche, le fait qu'il y ait
des pays jeunes
et des démocraties en Europe
qui sont, j'allais dire, vieillies
par leurs populations,
est-ce que ce décalage-là
est stratégiquement important ?
-Il est tout à fait fondamental
dans la mesure où je ne partage pas
l'optimisme de l'amiral Dufourcq
malheureusement.
J'aimerais croire
qu'il y ait une solution locale
pour cette jeunesse
qui attend d'avoir un avenir,
ce qui est normal.
Un pays comme l'Algérie,
30 % de la population
a moins de 15 ans.
Les trois quarts de la population
n'ont jamais connu
la guerre d'Algérie,
c'est la même chose
dans les autres pays du Maghreb.
Ce que je constate, c'est que,
et là, je vais peut-être
dire un gros mot,
mais j'ai l'impression
que ces gouvernements sont
assez contents en fait
de se débarrasser de leur jeunesse
en l'exportant vers la France.
En ce moment,
c'est particulièrement significatif
de la Tunisie malheureusement.
On en est
à près de 1000 personnes par jour
qui prennent la mer vers l'Italie,
qui arrivent en Italie.
Il y en a d'autres
malheureusement qui meurent.
Là-dedans, il y a aussi bien sûr
des gens de Côte-d'Ivoire notamment,
mais il y a beaucoup de jeunes
Tunisiens. L'émigration algérienne,
marocaine vers l'Europe
et la France en particulier
continue à plein régime.
C'est un vrai sujet.
Nous, en France, l'an dernier,
on a reçu quelque chose
comme 350 000 premiers visas
de séjour
et 150 000 demandes d'asile.
A terme, ça va profondément
menacer la cohésion de notre pays,
il faut le savoir.
La France est en train
de changer de peuple
sous l'impact de cette immigration.
Je crains malheureusement
que la solution de facilité
pour ces régimes
qui essaient de se maintenir
en place est
de se débarrasser d'une jeunesse
qu'ils ne peuvent pas
éduquer correctement
et encore moins employer.
-Pierre, je voudrais...
-On est dans un cercle
complètement vicieux.
-Pierre Lellouche,
je voudrais avoir
l'avis sur ce point-là
de Rachid Temal
et d'Hakim El Karoui,
cette dissociation, j'allais dire,
entre Maghreb et démocratie,
à travers
ce décalage démographique
et ce qui vient d'être dit
sur ces jeunes
qui quittent leurs pays.
-Il y a plusieurs questions.
Il y a plusieurs sujets
dans la question.
D'abord,
la France ne change pas de peuple
ou de peuplement.
On ne peut pas dire cela.
Il faut faire attention.
Ce n'est pas vrai.
Ensuite, on sait
que l'Europe a globalement
une pyramide des âges vieillissante.
Le continent africain a une pyramide
des âges plutôt jeune.
Ca, c'est un fait
et c'est pas lié,
voilà, c'est un fait. Après,
quand vous êtes jeune en Algérie,
pour un peu les connaître,
pour faire simple,
il y a à peu près deux façons.
Il y a ceux qui essaient
dans le système actuel,
beaucoup font maintenant du commerce
en Algérie, donc essaient de vivre
en Algérie et beaucoup essaient
de quitter l'Algérie.
C'est vrai qu'on a aujourd'hui,
notamment sur les côtes espagnoles,
beaucoup d'Algériens
qui essaient de fuir,
parce que, dans leur propre pays,
il n'y a pas d'horizon.
Ils ont parfois fait des études,
mais sans perspectives économiques.
La question qu'on dit depuis des
années sur l'Algérie, la question
de la crise du logement,
c'est toujours une réalité,
d'emploi, c'est une réalité,
et tout ça...
-Oui, mais vous dites
que c'est une défaite politique.
-Pour qui ?
-Pour l'Algérie.
Que ces jeunes
quittent le pays.
-Oui, il y en a qui restent,
il y en a qui partent,
parce que le pouvoir ne donne
aucune perspective à sa jeunesse,
comme le précédent gouvernement
avec le président de la République.
-En quoi
vous êtes en désaccord
avec Pierre Lellouche ?
-J'ai un point de désaccord majeur.
Pierre Lellouche dit, il évoquait
l'arrivée de populations de Tunisie
notamment et que la France,
sous cette pression-là,
changeait de peuple.
Il y a une théorie derrière cela
et je crois que c'est faux.
-Vous dites ça, Pierre Lellouche,
sur ce point précis ?
-Mon excellent ancien collègue
ou collègue Rachid Temal
peut affirmer ce qu'il veut
autant qu'il le veut,
mais ça change pas les choses.
Nous sommes encore une fois dans
une trajectoire migratoire en France
qui est profondément
en train de changer
la nature du peuple français.
Quand vous regardez
les statistiques,
c'est pas celles
de Monsieur Zemmour,
c'est celles de l'INSEE.
Elles vous disent
que 40 % des enfants en France
entre 0 et 4 ans
sont d'origine immigrée. 40 %.
Il suffit d'aller à la sortie
d'une école ou d'un lycée en France
pour voir à quel point
cette population a changé.
-Mais Monsieur Lellouche...
-Regardez les statistiques
démographiques.
-Pierre Lellouche, mon excellent
collègue Pierre Lellouche,
je vous ai pas attendu
pour aller voir les écoles
et comment ça se passait.
-Oh, écoutez...
-Oui, bah alors,
Pierre, laissez...
-C'est quand même regrettable,
je veux dire, juste regrettable
que sur un sujet aussi important,
aussi tangible, on puisse pas
avoir un dialogue calme.
-On va l'avoir.
-Il est très calme.
Nous sommes en désaccord.
Je vous ai dit juste que j'avais
un point de désaccord avec vous.
Je suis très, très calme.
-Soyez en désaccord
avec l'INSEE, pas avec moi.
-En fait, aujourd'hui,
je ne sais pas...
Non. Ces gens-là, que
vous évoquez là, sont des Français.
Ils sont français.
Donc on a ce point de divergence.
-Je vais vous donner
la parole. Pierre,
laissez-moi donner la parole
d'abord à Hakim El Karoui.
Hakim El Karoui,
sur ce point-là et en plus,
les statistiques, ça vous connaît.
-Oui. Ceux qui disent que la France
est en train de changer de peuple,
c'est la théorie
du grand remplacement,
c'est pas celle
d'Eric Zemmour, c'est celle de...
Comment il s'appelle ?
Cet écrivain médiocre. Bref.
C'est faux. Pourquoi ?
C'est pas qu'une question
de statistiques migratoires.
Ceux qui disent ça,
et je vous rejoins
et pardon, Pierre Lellouche,
je suis en désaccord avec vous,
ils oublient que la France
sait fabriquer des Français,
des nouveaux Français.
J'ai fait un rapport sur le sujet,
à l'Institut Montaigne,
et il sortira ailleurs, car
j'ai un désaccord avec l'Institut,
il est intitulé "Succès silencieux,
échecs criants".
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on ne voit pas
ce qui fonctionne.
Pourquoi on ne le voit pas ?
Parce que ça fonctionne.
Parce qu'il n'y a pas
la différence visible, l'échec,
la recherche identitaire
qui fait qu'il y a une opposition
avec le reste
de la population nationale.
On voit pas la majorité des succès,
on voit la minorité des échecs.
Et la force de la France,
la France est un pays d'immigration
depuis 150 ans,
depuis 1850,
depuis qu'on a des statistiques.
Aujourd'hui, les chiffres,
c'est à peu près
9, 10 % des Français
qui sont de confession musulmane,
c'est-à-dire qui viennent
du Maghreb,
d'Afrique subsaharienne musulmane
et qui viennent de Turquie.
Sur les naissances, on a 18 %
des naissances aujourd'hui qui sont,
qu'on peut qualifier,
qui viennent du monde arabe,
pas 40 %, 18 %. L'immigration
aujourd'hui, régulière,
40 % vient d'Afrique, Maghreb,
Afrique subsaharienne.
40 %. Donc pas 90 %.
40 %. Et, dans la dynamique
de l'immigration, ce qu'on voit,
c'est qu'en 10, 20, 30, 40 ans,
on fabrique des nouveaux Français.
Je vais vous dire quelque chose,
heureusement qu'on a l'immigration.
Aujourd'hui, on se plaint de quoi ?
On se plaint qu'il y a personne pour
faire des travaux peu qualifiés.
Les entrepreneurs, les entreprises
ont besoin de main-d'oeuvre.
Elle vient d'où
cette main-d'oeuvre ?
De la dynamique migratoire française
qui, contrairement à l'Allemande,
est régulière depuis les années 50
avec une baisse à partir de 1995
et une reprise sous Nicolas Sarkozy.
Quand la droite dit
qu'elle lutte
contre l'immigration,
dans les faits,
elle n'y arrive pas plus
que la gauche. Le sujet,
c'est qu'il faut, un, assumer,
que, un, on a besoin d'immigrés,
deux, que l'histoire de la France,
de sa population,
elle est faite d'immigration,
et que, trois,
peut-être le plus important,
le sujet dont on parle jamais,
c'est qu'on n'a aucune politique
pour réussir l'accueil
et l'intégration des immigrés
et surtout de leurs enfants.
-On va rentrer dans le détail.
Un mot, Pierre Lellouche,
et on passe à un autre sujet.
Vous vouliez réagir.
-Oui, d'abord,
je notais que
l'émission est intitulée
"La déconfiture du Maghreb"
et on a immédiatement parlé
de l'immigration en France,
ce qui montre à quel point
l'échec des uns
cause un énorme problème
à la France de l'autre.
Et moi, je suis pas dans la version
rose décrite par Monsieur El Karoui,
dont je connais les travaux,
que je respecte.
Mais malheureusement,
la situation est autre.
D'abord, je voudrais
lui rappeler que la France n'est pas
un pays d'immigration. Elle l'est
depuis la Première Guerre mondiale,
après les lois qui ont résulté
du désastre humain qui a été causé,
les premières grandes lois
sur l'immigration ont suivi
la Première Guerre mondiale
et l'immigration, à l'époque,
était essentiellement
d'origine européenne et chrétienne,
c'était des Italiens,
c'était des Espagnols,
c'était des gens
de l'Europe de l'Est.
-Il y avait des pogroms
à Aigues-Mortes à la fin du 19e
contre des Italiens,
que les Provençaux,
la Provence étant
une région déchristianisée
depuis longtemps,
considéraient comme trop chrétiens.
Non, c'est trop simple.
-Si je peux continuer. Ce qui a
radicalement changé, 10 ans après
la décolonisation, on a vu arriver
des vagues successives
de gens venant d'Afrique du Nord.
-C'est pas "on a vu arriver".
On a été chercher
pour reconstruire la France.
-D'abord pour la sauver
pendant la guerre.
-Voilà.
-Non, la France n'est pas un pays
d'immigration depuis toujours.
Certainement pas.
Après la Première Guerre mondiale
et la perte de 5 millions de jeunes
Français au cours du conflit,
il a fallu repeupler le pays
et la loi a fait qu'on a fait venir
des populations qui venaient
essentiellement de pays européens,
chrétiens, d'Italie, d'Espagne,
d'Europe centrale,
c'est la vérité incontestable.
Ce qui s'est passé ensuite
après la décolonisation,
et je rappelle
que le général de Gaulle
est parti d'Algérie précisément
à cause de ce facteur démographique
et la crainte de voir
des vagues migratoires.
Il voulait tourner
la page de cette histoire
vers l'Algérie. On a vu arriver
des vagues migratoires
avec la bénédiction
du patronat français à l'époque
qui faisait venir d'abord
des gens sans leurs familles,
puis après le regroupement
familial en 76, on est passé
à une immigration de masse
et de peuplement
qui a profondément
changé la structure
urbaine et nationale du pays.
C'est une réalité.
-On vous a entendu.
Rachid Temal, une réaction,
avant de passer à autre chose.
-J'ai aussi beaucoup de respect
pour le ministre Lellouche. La
vérité, c'est que ce qu'il assène,
c'est faux. La France, dans
ses frontières et dans son peuple,
c'est une terre d'immigration.
Il peut dire ce qu'il veut.
Je vais assez vite.
Monsieur Lellouche, relisez,
dans l'entre-deux-guerres notamment,
ce qui était écrit sur les Polonais
ou sur les Italiens.
Il y avait des endroits
interdits aux chiens
et aux Polonais ou aux Italiens.
Ils étaient chrétiens. Comme quoi,
la réécriture est intéressante.
Ensuite, vous évoquez
une autre immigration.
En fait, ils ne sont pas venus
après la décolonisation,
ils sont venus
pendant la guerre
pour sauver la France,
puis pour la reconstruire.
C'est ce qu'il s'est passé.
Je vous le dis, oui,
il y a des millions de Français,
je crois qu'il y a des études,
il y a des millions de Français
qui ont des origines étrangères,
qui sont des parfaits Français.
Il faut faire attention
à ce discours.
-30 %.
-Ce sont des parfaits Français.
Je donne mon exemple concret,
je suis le premier
de ma famille à être né
français et à être français.
C'est simple. On est des Français.
C'est la richesse,
la beauté de la France de savoir
effectivement faire
de tous ces individus-là
des Français.
-Il peut y avoir un désaccord.
Alors, Jean Dufourcq, il y a une
question que je voudrais vous poser
qui a été invoquée
de manière subliminaire à travers
les différents propos.
Selon Pierre Nora,
l'histoire rassemble,
mais la mémoire
divise et sépare.
On semble le confondre
à propos du Maghreb, parce que
l'Algérie, le Maroc et la Tunisie
sont à la fois une affaire
diplomatique et une affaire
intérieure. Est-ce que
cet entre-deux, cet emmêlement,
est-ce qu'il vous paraît
permettre de voir
les véritables problèmes
qui se posent en France
ou dans les pays du Maghreb
ou est-ce que tout ça s'emmêle ?
-C'est une question
tout à fait intéressante
que le chercheur a envie d'analyser.
Là, peut-être qu'il y a au départ
une idée fausse,
l'idée que les trois pays auraient
eu des trajectoires comparables.
Chacun de ces pays a
sa propre histoire.
Si on parle de la Tunisie, elle a
une histoire assez différente
des deux autres pays.
Et donc chacun vient
avec sa propre histoire,
chacun vient avec ses rêves,
ses frustrations, son passé,
ses gloires et ses difficultés.
Si l'on part de cela,
eh bien, on comprend
assez bien, j'allais dire,
que l'histoire peut un peu diviser
et peut aussi renvoyer
à chacun une image différente.
La relation
entre la France et chacun
des trois pays du Maghreb a eu
sa propre trajectoire
et cette trajectoire
est plus ou moins ancienne
et donc ce qui apparaît aujourd'hui,
c'est que les miroirs
que l'on renvoie sont
des miroirs très différents
et je crois que c'est l'idée même
de Maghreb qu'il faudrait
interroger. L'idée de Maghreb
est une idée peut-être plus moderne,
plus récente et géographique,
elle n'est pas encore
complètement sociologique.
Il faudrait pour cela que naisse
ce que moi je crois percevoir,
je crois qu'il y a une conscience
de la jeunesse maghrébine
qui est en train de se créer
avec un langage, une vision
qui n'est pas du tout tournée
vers le passé, mais sur l'avenir.
-Je reviens
sur ma question, Rachid Temal.
Question intérieure, question
extérieure, emmêlement des choses,
on a l'impression
que tout ça se mêle.
-Je vais vous parler de l'Algérie.
Sur l'Algérie, c'est à la fois
une question intérieure
et une question extérieure.
D'abord, parce que
c'était trois départements.
Bon. Deuxième chose, si on se dit
les choses tranquillement,
personne n'a entre guillemets soldé
la question de la guerre d'Algérie.
Si je prends
les formations politiques,
en commençant par ma famille.
La gauche est celle
qui a permis
les pouvoirs spéciaux à l'armée
avec tout ce que ça a engendré.
Elle n'a jamais voulu
échanger, discuter,
regarder en face son histoire.
La droite,
c'est celle qui, le 13 mai 58,
rappelle de Gaulle
en espérant conserver l'Algérie :
"Je vous ai compris."
Et c'est celui qui fera
l'indépendance. Donc aucune
des formations politiques
de notre pays n'a évoqué cela.
D'ailleurs, à tel point,
quand vous évoquez la question
notamment
avec les Français d'Algérie,
ils ont débarqué, on leur a
dit, nous emmerdez pas,
passez votre chemin,
les Harkis, pareil.
On n'a jamais fait ce travail.
Je suis d'accord avec Monsieur Nora,
mais en disant que les mémoires
divisent, c'est vrai,
mais elles sont
surtout complémentaires.
Il faut aller dans cette notion.
Il y a une complémentarité
des histoires en fonction
de qui vous êtes et c'est ça
qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui.
Pour en terminer, j'étais à Alger
avec le président Macron
et avec la Première ministre,
je suis très heureux du travail
sur l'ensemble de la période
de la mémoire, 1830-1962,
avec les 6 ou 5 historiens
de part et d'autre.
Il faut faire ce travail
d'histoire, il n'est pas fait.
Ca permettrait de dire,
il y a une histoire commune,
qui est à la fois
douloureuse et heureuse,
ensuite, il y a l'avenir.
Aujourd'hui, quand on prend
les deux pays, ils ont
des problèmes assez similaires.
Sur la question sécuritaire,
de la sécurité
alimentaire ou énergétique,
c'est deux géants
qui pourraient mieux se parler,
la France et l'Algérie.
-Mais côté Maroc, Tunisie,
c'est moins emmêlé
si on peut dire, non ? Qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez, Hakim El Karoui ?
Les pays restent
dans une indépendance
et d'esprit et de politique.
On a moins le sentiment
que les choses
sont mêlées ?
-Non, je dirais pas ça.
C'est très imbriqué.
Après, il y a un usage politique
qui est pas exactement
le même qu'en Algérie.
Parce que les régimes ont
un peu moins besoin
de l'opposition française
pour exister.
Parce qu'ils sont pas nés seulement
dans l'opposition
ou la guerre avec la France.
Mais la présence française
est très forte.
Ce qui est intéressant,
c'est la région avec laquelle
la France a une relation
qui n'est pas une relation
de politique étrangère,
parce qu'il y a une histoire commune
extraordinaire, complexe,
des populations communes
des deux côtés,
avec 500 000 Franco-Algériens
en Algérie
et 4, 5, 6 millions de descendants
de Maghrébins au sens large,
y compris les juifs
d'Algérie, les appelés
du contingent, les harkis,
en France. Donc on est dans une zone
qui est intéressante,
parce qu'elle invente quelque chose.
Quand on a des populations
en commun, une histoire,
une langue, même si le français
se perd un peu au Maghreb,
en fait, il y a un objet politique
spécifique qui se crée, d'où
cette omniprésence de la France
du point de vue
du sud et d'où aussi probablement la
difficulté pour la France d'inventer
une politique soit maghrébine
soit avec les pays du Maghreb.
Parce que la France gère
d'abord l'héritage.
L'héritage, c'est l'histoire,
c'est une présence avec du capital,
avec un appareil diplomatique
extraordinairement important,
le plus important
du monde
avec l'Allemagne et les Etats-Unis,
et elle gère les crises. Mais
elle n'a pas de projet politique.
Quand on regarde en Tunisie,
le président tunisien
a compris une chose :
les Européens, leur seule politique
avec le Maghreb, c'est la lutte
contre l'immigration clandestine.
Il leur dit,
je vais lutter avec vous
et en échange, vous me donnez de
l'argent et vous me foutez la paix.
Ca veut dire qu'il y a tellement
plus de projet politique que
l'inquiétude de Pierre Lellouche,
très zemmourienne, pardon pour lui,
c'est ça qui fait la politique de la
France au Maghreb. Et c'est pour ça
que ça marche pas. Il faut
un projet politique à l'échelle,
au niveau de notre engagement
politique avec le Maghreb.
-Sur cette question,
Pierre Lellouche,
l'imbrication affaires intérieures,
affaires extérieures,
qu'en pensez-vous ?
-Là, je rejoins Rachid Temal,
je pense qu'il y a
une vraie différence
entre l'Algérie
et les deux autres. L'Algérie,
c'était trois départements français
et donc il y a ce lien qui,
des deux côtés, est très important,
surtout du côté algérien.
Dans les deux autres cas,
la Tunisie, qui était un protectorat
et le Maroc, qui a
toujours été un royaume,
il y a deux histoires différentes et
peut-être un éloignement plus grand
et moins d'exploitation
de cette histoire de mémoire.
Les Marocains sont
très patriotes, très nationalistes.
Mais généralement, je considère
que ce mélange des genres,
que cultive d'ailleurs à mon sens à
tort le président de la République,
ne rend service à personne.
La majorité de la population dans
les pays du Maghreb n'était pas là
à l'indépendance.
-On poursuit avec vous,
Jean Dufourcq. Il y a un problème
de sécurité, il y a un problème
de terrorisme. Ce terrorisme est
en Afrique, il est aussi
en Tunisie. Pourquoi on n'arrive pas
à se mettre d'accord
sur une politique
de sécurité commune ?
-Je crois que c'est assez simple.
C'est qu'on n'identifie pas
les mêmes choses derrière
la notion de terrorisme.
Derrière cette notion, il y a
toujours trois choses profondes.
Il y a des questions de séparatisme,
qui existent toujours.
Il y a une question
de grande criminalité
et cette question
de grande criminalité,
c'est lié à des régimes politiques
qui ne savent pas
gérer, je dirais, l'ordre public.
Ces trois questions sont
intimement mêlées.
Ce qui fait
qu'on ne sait pas les résoudre
si on n'identifie pas
de quoi on parle.
Le mot terrorisme est
un mot complexe.
Vous vous souvenez
que les Etats-Unis en inventant
la guerre globale contre le
terrorisme ont brouillé les cartes.
Nous ne savons pas gérer cela.
Les trois pays
ne font pas face
aux mêmes questions.
En plus, là, il faudrait
repartir du Maghreb. En Tunisie,
on regarde beaucoup la Libye,
vers le sud.
La question du terrorisme
n'est pas posée de la même façon
qu'en Algérie et la question
du Polisario pour le Maroc
relève aussi du terrorisme.
Chacun a au fond
son propre terrorisme,
sa propre histoire
et sa propre géographie.
Et tout ça fait que l'Algérie
avec ses deux territoires,
sa bande côtière et le reste,
il y a donc là des politiques
qui ne peuvent pas être coordonnées
et comme il n'y a pas
une vision d'avenir commune,
chaque pays ne tire pas
dans la même direction. Il veut
solder des problèmes intérieurs
avant les problèmes globaux.
-De la sécurité, on va passer
à des choses plus positives,
on va passer à l'économie.
A l'instar d'autres pays africains,
les trois pays du Maghreb
participent de la mondialisation
en nouant des partenariats
économiques privilégiés.
Qui avec l'Europe, qui avec
la Chine, la Russie, la Turquie,
l'ensemble du monde arabe,
le Brésil, Israël, etc.
Mais il n'y a pas
d'intégration économique.
A votre avis,
pourquoi, Rachid Temal ?
-Il faudrait une thèse.
Mais d'abord,
on peut rappeler qu'il y avait
un projet Maghreb 2000. Ce qu'on
constate, c'est qu'il y avait
il fut un temps une volonté
et sans résultat.
Après, c'est des économies
très différentes
et je crois
qu'aucune de ces trois économies
n'a aussi réussi
à avoir un niveau...
Alors, l'Algérie a son rapport
à l'hydrocarbure,
mais aucun des trois pays n'a
un niveau de capacité de manufacture
conséquente
qui vous permet de commercer.
C'est un vrai sujet.
Quand vous voulez être
dans le monde, il faut vendre.
Ont-ils des services
formidables ? Pas vraiment.
Ont-ils de la manufacture ?
Pas vraiment.
C'est très compliqué pour eux
d'aller commercer.
Les trois pays ont du mal
à commercer ensemble.
L'Algérie et la Tunisie,
ça fait 40 ans qu'ils s'ouvrent
la frontière et la ferment.
-Le Maroc.
-J'ai dit ? Pardon.
Entre le Maroc
et l'Algérie,
ça fait 40 ans que ça dure.
Les frontières se ferment. Parfois,
elles s'ouvrent. C'est pas facile
pour faire du commerce ensemble.
En plus, les deux pays ont une
vision historiquement de Panafrique,
ils sont en concurrence aussi
sur ces questions-là.
Quant à la Tunisie, c'est un peu
plus compliqué, son rapport
économique à l'Algérie est
plus dépendant.
D'un mot sur la sécurité,
qui impacte l'économie,
quand vous prenez les trois pays,
à leur est,
ils ont un pays totalement détruit
qui s'appelle la Libye.
Vous avez une bande terroriste
qui plonge jusqu'au Tchad.
Et par le sud, vous avez notamment
le Mali avec ce qu'on a connu là.
En termes de sécurité, en général,
le business et la sécurité,
ça fait pas vraiment bon ménage.
Les trois pays ont
à la fois un problème interne,
à construire une économie,
et un problème
à avoir un pôle de stabilité.
-D'accord, mais quand même,
Hakim El Karoui,
pourquoi cette impossibilité,
peut-être pas de faire
un marché commun, mais d'avancer
vers une perspective
économique commune ?
-Parce qu'on a des tribus
qui sont en guerre les unes contre
les autres, ce qui est traditionnel
dans le monde arabe.
-On pourrait dire "berbérois".
-Au 21e siècle, c'est dommage,
mais il y a cette idée que
le voisin, l'autre, le plus proche
est un concurrent.
Et jamais un collègue,
jamais quelqu'un
avec qui on va coopérer.
On va toujours travailler
avec des gens loin
et toujours se méfier
des gens proches.
Et malheureusement, c'est comme ça
que ça fonctionne,
pas seulement au Maghreb,
dans tout le monde arabe.
Les accords de libre-échange
d'Agadir n'ont jamais été appliqués
nulle part dans le monde arabe.
Pour autant, je pense
que l'avenir du Maghreb,
c'est pas la manufacture,
c'est les services et notamment
pour les Marocains et les Tunisiens.
L'économie algérienne
est très différente.
Les Marocains et les Tunisiens ont
un avantage comparatif par rapport
à tout le reste
de la Méditerranée,
ils ont en commun une culture,
en bonne partie une langue,
et puis, les fameux échanges
migratoires dont on parle,
ils ont construit
des savoir-faire de prise en charge
des gens, des savoir-faire médicaux,
des savoir-faire hôteliers,
il y a un énorme marché
d'économie du service
autour de la prise en charge
des riches Européens
dans les pays plus pauvres du sud
de la Méditerranée,
la Tunisie et le Maroc.
Prenez le sujet des retraites.
Derrière,
c'est le sujet de la santé.
Comment on va financer
le vieillissement, pas de la France,
de toute l'Europe occidentale ?
On sait pas faire.
Il va falloir faire baisser
les prix. Une façon est d'exporter,
ça veut dire industrialiser
la venue non pas
des jeunes Maghrébins
qui vont travailler en France,
même si on en a besoin,
mais la venue
des jeunes retraités européens,
soit parce qu'ils auront besoin
de soins de santé,
soit parce qu'ils vont passer
une partie de leur retraite
dans les pays du Maghreb.
Et ça, on peut le faire
qu'au Maghreb, pas en Turquie,
en Egypte, en Jordanie,
car on est très loin culturellement.
Il faut faire levier
sur notre histoire,
y compris sur la colonisation,
on vit en commun, on se connaît.
Aujourd'hui,
qui prend soin des personnes âgées
en France dans les EHPAD ? Ce sont
des jeunes femmes
la plupart d'origine maghrébine
ou subsaharienne. Plutôt qu'agiter
la haine, la peur,
et pardon, Pierre Lellouche,
je suis vraiment choqué
par vos propos, essayons
de travailler sur ce qui nous unit.
Ce qui nous unit, c'est notre passé
commun et notre avenir commun.
-Pierre Lellouche,
sur cette question économique,
comment expliquez-vous
cette difficulté pour les pays
du Maghreb à commercer entre eux
et à créer justement quelque chose,
une forme d'union économique ?
-D'abord, je voudrais répondre
à Monsieur El Karoui pour lui dire
que c'est moi qui suis choqué.
Dire le réel dans ces pays,
ce n'est pas appeler à la haine,
au contraire.
C'est l'aveuglement
qui fait le terreau de la haine
et je lui dis de faire
attention à ses mots.
Je suis pas là pour faire
de la propagande raciste,
je sais trop ce que c'est
que le racisme.
Donc essayez d'avoir les yeux
grand ouverts sur votre pays.
-J'ai eu les yeux grand ouverts.
J'ai fait depuis 6 ans beaucoup
de travaux sérieux, quantitatifs,
sur ces questions. J'ai toujours
dit ce qui va et ce qui va pas.
Pas seulement ce qui va pas.
-Je peux pas continuer ma phrase ?
Venons-en à la question
sur pourquoi ces trois pays
ne coopèrent pas.
Pour une raison simple.
Dans le cas de l'Algérie,
qui est le pays le plus riche,
les choix de la direction
militaro-sécuritaire,
c'est l'hydrocarbure et de vivre
de cette rente-là et ils n'ont pas
développé le pays.
Les choix de Ben Ali,
c'était le tourisme
de masse européen
et ça a à peu près fonctionné, mais
le reste du pays est très pauvre
et ça a donné la révolution de 2011.
Le Maroc, lui, a fait des efforts
de développement et
d'industrialisation considérables.
Je vous recommande d'aller à Tanger
et regarder y compris
ce que nous avons fait,
y compris
quand j'étais au gouvernement,
en termes de délocalisation. On a
fabriqué des usines d'automobiles,
on a exporté des moyens
de transport modernes.
Le Maroc a construit
un système bancaire,
un système de services
qui est extrêmement performant
dans le monde africain
et eux sont en train de bâtir une
économie qui est assez convaincante.
Après, il reste
naturellement la question
du Sahara occidental
et la tension avec l'Algérie,
qui est un frein supplémentaire
à la coopération entre les pays.
Mais tout ça, ça veut dire quoi ?
Que les idées d'un grand Maghreb
économique n'existent
que dans les rêves des Européens,
pas dans la tête
des acteurs sur place.
Chacun a son mode de développement.
Je sais pas si c'est une constante
du monde arabe. Peut-être.
En même temps, je note,
pour le regretter d'ailleurs,
que les pays qui ont
de l'argent dans le Golfe
mettent très peu d'argent
dans le Maghreb.
La Tunisie a besoin
d'investissements,
l'argent vient pas du Golfe
et c'est tout à fait
regrettable. Donc il n'y a pas
de communauté là aussi,
d'envie de développer ces pays
qui pourraient l'être.
-Merci.
-C'est dû à l'échec général
de ce système.
-Merci, Pierre.
Jean Dufourcq.
-Je rebondis
sur cette question
que je trouve importante.
Il faut élargir le champ du Maghreb
vers les pays latins
qui sont en face.
Les trois frères maghrébins,
on les connaît.
Il y a en face trois soeurs latines
dont on parle moins.
Je crois qu'il y a là
une possibilité
de travailler
de façon plus globale.
Les pays de la vieille Europe,
la France, l'Espagne, l'Italie,
sont un peu marginalisés
dans l'Europe d'aujourd'hui
dirigée par la Pologne
avec un regard différent,
et je crois que nous redécouvrons
la communauté de nos intérêts
entre les trois pays,
les trois soeurs latines.
Nous pourrions faire
l'effort collectif,
nous sommes 180 M sur la rive nord
de la Méditerranée occidentale,
il y a 100 M de Maghrébins
en face de nous,
au plan économique en particulier.
Je voudrais ajouter un 2e point.
Ceci a été déjà largement commenté,
mais nous avons parlé de ça avec des
Italiens il y a pas très longtemps.
Il y a une vingtaine d'années,
on travaillait
sur le processus de Barcelone
et on réfléchissait à l'équation
magique, l'argent du Golfe,
la technologie des soeurs latines
ou de l'Europe en général
et la capacité de production
de délocalisation
sur la côte d'Afrique du Nord
d'un certain nombre d'industries
ou de services comme vous l'avez dit
et qui permettraient à tous d'être
dans une logique gagnant-gagnant.
Ca n'a pas marché essentiellement
pour des raisons accessoires,
secondaires. Le terrorisme bien sûr
et puis le changement du monde
à l'époque. Et donc
tout cela a créé une condition
qui n'a pas permis de mobiliser
ces trois outils simultanément
pour pouvoir créer un développement
qui soit de bonne qualité
et qui soit durable et qui laissait
chacun un peu chez soi aussi
au centre de gravité
de ses qualités.
-Alors,
d'un point de vue
géostratégique, Jean,
aujourd'hui, sans qu'il y ait
une nouvelle Guerre froide,
le monde se divise en quelque sorte
entre des puissances
dites autoritaires,
certains disent des dictatures,
on pense à la Russie, à la Chine,
etc., ces pays autoritaires.
Et de l'autre côté, les démocraties.
Est-ce que, par rapport
à cette division,
le Maghreb vous paraît avoir,
devoir s'aligner quelque part
ou vouloir jouer
une position non alignée
qui pour certains pays est
plus proche des pays autoritaires
et pour d'autres, vers l'Occident ?
-La question du non-alignement
est fondamentale
dans l'époque que nous vivons, 2023.
L'obligation d'alignement
est en train d'écrêter
un certain nombre d'initiatives.
Il serait souhaitable
que nous arrivions à créer
cette communauté andalouse,
dont on a parlé il y a 20 ans,
rappelez-vous,
cette communauté andalouse
dans laquelle
les pays qui sont gestionnaires
d'un même espace
arrivent à retrouver
sans conditionnalité politique
des intérêts communs
qui permettent de les rassembler
dans une communauté
réellement au service des peuples.
Et là, l'alignement sur l'autorité
ou sur la démocratie a
moins de sens. Il faut bien dire
que la démocratie est déclinée de
façon très variée et l'autoritarisme
est lié finalement à l'histoire
d'un certain nombre de pays
qui cherchent leur propre chemin.
Je crois que cette dichotomie
ou ce clivage
n'est pas pertinent aujourd'hui.
Il faut revenir
à une forme de régionalisme,
en tout cas,
le stratégiste vous dira cela,
dans lequel les intérêts communs
seront plus faciles à percevoir.
La régionalisation
permet de retrouver
des solidarités immédiates.
La Méditerranée occidentale,
si elle savait se concevoir,
aurait des outils
pour se développer
dans l'intérêt général.
-Pierre Lellouche, un mot
sur la question du Maghreb
par rapport aux puissances
autoritaires et aux démocraties.
Un mot là-dessus.
Est-ce que, pour le Maghreb,
c'est mieux de choisir,
si je puis dire,
l'Occident démocratique,
ou d'aller
vers ces puissances autoritaires
qui constituent quand même 60 %
de la population mondiale ?
Rachid Temal.
-Il y a déjà une réalité,
c'est qu'on sait bien
que les rapports,
je vais reparler de l'Algérie,
France-Algérie sont distendus
depuis des années,
il y a beaucoup de choses
du gouvernement algérien,
mais en France, on a notamment fermé
toute la politique de visas,
en tout cas réduite,
notamment sur les étudiants.
Un des outils de soft power
pour la France est
d'emmener des étudiants,
de les former.
Mais déjà, aujourd'hui,
il faut pas qu'on se mente.
Sur la question militaire,
l'alliance historique
est avec la Russie pour l'Algérie.
Dans le business, quand vous allez
en Algérie, la Chine est partout.
Les bailleurs de fonds de l'Algérie,
c'est beaucoup ces pays-là.
-Vous le déplorez ?
-Je le déplore à titre personnel,
mais si j'élargis, je sors
de ma condition personnelle,
tous ces pays africains
pour une grande part,
les trois qu'on connaît,
mais plus largement,
ils ont été colonisés et depuis,
ils ont des relations privilégiées
avec la France.
Toutes les populations sont-elles
heureuses de leur développement ?
Elles font
comme dans le monde entier,
il y a plusieurs compétiteurs
de services,
on regarde le plus offrant.
C'est ce qui passe
sur l'arrivée des Russes
et pas qu'avec Wagner,
mais notamment,
l'arrivée des Chinois,
l'arrivée des Turcs aussi
via l'entrée de la Libye
et vous en avez partout.
Donc aujourd'hui, tous ces pays sont
très largement concurrencés.
Ca devient des zones de concurrence
pour des compétiteurs
internationaux.
-On va conclure
là-dessus.
Hakim El Karoui, finalement,
à travers tout ce qu'on a dit
au cours de cette émission,
envers et malgré tout,
est-ce que le Maghreb
est une chance pour la France
et réciproquement ?
-Alors, là, je vais
citer Pierre Lellouche.
Je vais dire que
c'est une réalité pour la France.
Je sais pas si c'est une chance
ou une malchance,
en tout cas, ça existe et il faut
qu'on vive avec. Il faut arrêter
de croire qu'on va pouvoir laisser
la question maghrébine
et des Maghrébins
très loin de notre horizon
politique. Et pour ça,
il faut se poser la question de
ce qu'on a envie de faire.
Il y a 20 ans, il y avait
l'idée d'une intégration
économique, pas trop
politique, c'était compliqué
et c'est resté compliqué.
On a abandonné
cette idée d'intégration économique,
y compris parce que
ça a assez largement échoué.
Moi, je crois
qu'il faut faire du judo.
Le judo, c'est, c'est où la valeur
et c'est où l'avantage comparatif
qu'on a. L'avantage
comparatif qu'on a,
c'est qu'on se connaît les uns
les autres extrêmement bien,
on vit ensemble
dans une forme de fureur, mais aussi
de passion. On a plein de choses
à faire. Il faut juste arrêter
de se dire qu'on se déteste.
On se déteste
pas tant que ça. On prend soin
les uns des autres. Faisons levier
et faisons de cela
un projet économique
et du coup un projet politique.
-Jean Dufourcq, diagnostic,
une chance
pour la France, pour l'Europe
et vice versa ?
-A l'évidence,
rien n'est plus important
pour la France que le Maghreb
et rien n'est plus important
dans le Maghreb pour la France
que l'Algérie, retrouver un chemin
de coopération et de coexistence
qui débouche
sur quelque chose de plus large.
Je crois que, oui, c'est une chance.
Nous devons faire quelque chose.
Nous sommes obligés de le faire,
c'est notre intérêt,
nous trouverons aussi des retours
très positifs
dans notre société française
qui regarde cela
comme une sorte d'OVNI
trop difficile à gérer.
Il faut y aller.
-Rachid Temal ?
Sur ce point ?
-J'ai un rêve.
Moins de 20 ans à peu près
après la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
vous avez eu
le traité de l'Elysée.
On est 60 ans après, il faudrait un
traité soit de l'Elysée soit d'Alger
entre la France et l'Algérie,
c'est maintenant l'enjeu
pour la France notamment
dans cette zone-là du monde.
-C'est pas trop tard ?
-Je ne pense pas.
Les populations, comme
vous le disiez, sont toujours là.
La réalité est toujours là.
Il faut aller vers cela.
Un traité d'amitié
entre les deux peuples.
-Nous avons quelques problèmes
de connexion avec Pierre Lellouche,
mais nous l'avons au téléphone.
Alors, Pierre Lellouche, à votre
tour de conclure sur un pronostic.
Est-ce que vous diriez
que, malgré tout,
le Maghreb est une chance
pour la France et pour l'Europe
et vice versa ?
-Clairement, l'Europe sera
une chance pour le Maghreb,
parce que le Maghreb continuera
à avoir besoin
des transferts d'argent,
des technologies
et surtout d'accueil
pour sa jeunesse.
Donc l'Europe restera
très importante pour le Maghreb.
Pour nous, je crains malheureusement
que ça reste un énorme fardeau.
Et nous payons, il faut être clair,
nous payons notre colonisation.
Voilà. Et donc, nous sommes
la zone de destination
de l'immigration
de toute cette jeunesse
qui ne trouve pas à avoir d'avenir
dans les pays d'origine
et qui naturellement viendra,
surtout en France d'ailleurs.
82 % des immigrés algériens
viennent en France.
C'est l'histoire de la colonisation,
c'est la langue,
et donc, pour nous,
ça restera un énorme fardeau
en termes de capacité d'accueil
et d'intégration de ces populations,
avec la question fondamentale
du devenir de l'islam.
Est-ce que l'islam est compatible
ou non avec la République ?
Est-ce que l'islam reste
une affaire personnelle,
de foi personnelle
parfaitement respectable ?
Ou bien est-ce qu'elle continuera
à être tiraillée par tous ceux
qui essaient de l'exploiter
à des fins politiques ?
Je pense aux frères musulmans et aux
fondamentalistes qui sont en train
de gangréner jour après jour
nos banlieues, nos institutions.
Et pour nous,
c'est un véritable fardeau.
Il faut regarder les choses
malheureusement en face.
-Merci, Pierre Lellouche.
Dans un autre ordre d'idée,
est-ce que vous avez
un livre à conseiller ?
-Le dernier livre que j'ai sorti
en 2017 parle
de l'échec effectivement
des expériences postcoloniales
dans le Maghreb,
un livre qui s'appelle
"Une guerre sans fin",
publié aux éditions du Cerf en 2017
et qui parle de la poussée
de l'islam radical en Europe
à partir du terreau de l'échec
des expériences postcoloniales
dans le monde arabe
et notamment dans le Maghreb.
-Merci, Pierre Lellouche.
Le moment est venu de vous présenter
une brève bibliographie.
Alors, je voudrais rappeler
que la revue Hérodote a consacré
un important dossier au Maghreb.
C'est paru
au premier trimestre 2021.
Et le dossier est
assez riche d'ailleurs
sur l'ensemble du Maghreb.
Je voudrais rappeler
de Pierre Vermeren, professeur
à la Sorbonne, "Déni français,
"notre histoire secrète
des relations franco-arabes"
chez Albin Michel.
Je voudrais également
rappeler un livre
qui a soulevé de grands débats,
livre de l'ambassadeur
Xavier Driencourt,
qui a été ambassadeur de France
en Algérie, qui a publié :
Aux éditions de l'Observatoire.
Jean Dufourcq, qui est avec nous,
a publié de très nombreux
articles,
notamment sur la Méditerranée
et le Maghreb dans la Revue
de défense nationale
dont il a été le rédacteur en chef.
Hakim El Karoui, vous avez publié
de très nombreux ouvrages,
on peut, puisqu'on a évoqué
la situation française,
vous avez également publié
un livre sur l'islam :
Il a paru chez Le Débat Gallimard.
Un mot là-dessus,
ça évolue un peu la situation
de l'islam français ? Un mot.
-Ca a du mal à trouver
son organisation,
mais il y a une bonne nouvelle,
c'est que maintenant,
on ne dépend plus du CFCM,
c'est-à-dire
de l'ingérence turque,
algérienne
et des organisations marocaines.
On est passé au Forum de l'Islam
de France, qui est naissant,
mais qui est fondé sur des gens
français, indépendants,
de bonne volonté. C'est
nouveau et avec ça,
on devrait pouvoir construire
quelque chose de bien.
En même temps,
le vrai sujet est pas là,
il est dans l'emprise
sur la définition religieuse
auprès des jeunes
des quartiers populaires
qui sont en quête identitaire.
La réponse ne sera jamais
institutionnelle. Elle sera sur
le terrain, sur les réseaux sociaux.
-Merci. Rachid Temal, il y a
un livre
que vous voulez promouvoir ?
-Pas spécialement,
vous avez présenté assez de livres
pour éclairer vos téléspectateurs.
-Il me reste à vous remercier
d'avoir participé à cette émission.
Merci à l'équipe de LCP
de l'avoir permise,
et avant de nous quitter,
je voulais vous soumettre
cette pensée de Béatrice Giblin
qui est d'ailleurs
la rédactrice en chef
de l'excellente revue Hérodote :
"Les relations du Maghreb
avec la France sont
"ô combien plus intenses
et plus étroites
"qu'elles ne l'étaient
pendant la colonisation."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA